[Musica]
salve buonasera sono paolo bini sono
un'artista la mia passione l'arte ma
l'arte qualcosa di generico generale la
mia arte
la mia pittura i miei quadri sono la mia
passione
io riesco fortunatamente a vivere di
questa mia passione ea vivere nel mio
lavoro fin da bambino ho sempre avuto
questa grande attitudine alle immagini
alla possibilità di tradurre in emozioni
poi più in avanti anche studiando in
accademia tradurre attraverso delle
immagini
il sentire dell'essere umano
il mio lavoro la mia passione mi ha
portato in vari posti dell'italia e
anche del mondo ed ho avuto la fortuna
anche di vincere delle borse di studio o
dei premi in vari nazione in vari
nazioni dove ho avuto la possibilità di
lavorare per dei periodi e di farmi
attraversare dai luoghi in cui ho
lavorato
questi luoghi mi hanno cambiato il modo
di percepire la natura il paesaggio ma
soprattutto gli esseri umani le persone
il mio lavoro consiste diciamo così
nella pittura ma realizzò anche delle
grandi installazioni come vedete questa
le mie spalle che è un palazzo storico a
genova a palazzo bianco dove conservato
anche un ecce homo di caravaggio e ho
ridisegnato
come dire l'architettura di questo luogo
questo invece è una mostra realizzata
per la tredicesima settimana della
cultura italiana a l'avana a cuba e
questo invece un momento molto
importante della mia vita del mio lavoro
dove ho iniziato qui sono in sudafrica a
città del capo a realizzare le mie opere
o meglio ho cercato e sto cercando
ancora oggi mettendo a punto una tecnica
particolare di realizzare le mie opere
ovvero di fare pittura in un modo nuovo
in che senso mi spiego oggi come dire
l'immagine ha un'attitudine che va verso
il digitale
come dire il pixel il frame sono tutta
una serie di metodi tecniche o meglio
una composizione dell'immagine con il
quale noi la vediamo costantemente e
quotidianamente su degli schermi io
recupero questo concetto essendo calato
totalmente nella pittura
in questo modo ho iniziato a realizzare
i miei lavori attraverso delle strisce
di nastro carta che attraversano i
paesaggi in cui io sono stato e sono
ancora e attraverso queste grandi
astrazioni vado a realizzare delle opere
che hanno un carattere pervasivo in
grado di ridisegnare delle architetture
degli spazi e facendo trasformando il
paesaggio visto in paesaggio sentito
queste sono una serie di opere astratte
realizzate con questi nastri dipinti in
acrilico e poi integrate su queste tele
questa varie soluzioni appunto di questi
quadri che hanno un racconto appunto di
tutto questo paesaggio che si intravede
nella sovrapposizione di questi nastri
ci sono delle soluzioni anche
monocromatiche e queste invece un'opera
molto lirica dove c'è una sorta di suono
dentro a questo tipo di lavoro e quindi
è come se il quadro si unisse con
l'esterno in questo senso qui nel corso
dei miei va dei miei viaggi nel corso
del mio lavoro della mia ricerca
artistica mi sono imbattuto anche con
persone con personalità e con questa
opera
ho vinto la diciassettesima edizione del
premio cairo che è una delle dei premi
più importanti per la giovane arte
italiana è sostenuto da un grande
imprenditore quale urbano cairo ed ho
avuto il piacere e l'onore di essere il
primo artista campano ad aver vinto in
occasione del 17 selezione quindi nel
2016 questo premio sono proprio con
cairo mentre mi consegna per l'appunto
il titolo di vincitore diciamo così
ma dopo questa breve presentazione non
voglio annoiarvi su quella che è la mia
pratica artistica perché poi la pratica
artistica la si deve guardare restare
magari nello studio dell'artista vedere
una mostra a guardare i quadri intendo
fare oggi un piccolo focus su il perché
ho deciso di fare questo tipo di
intervento e legare la passione al mio
lavoro che è l'arte nel momento in cui è
stata riaperta la collezione terrae
motus le attività artistiche
contemporanee della reggia di caserta
grazie al settore della valorizzazione
hanno voluto invitare made in
collaborazione con la galleria nicola
pedana di caserta a realizzare una
mostra nel e retrostanze del settecento
e oggi siccome la mostra è stata dal 18
dicembre 2016 al febbraio del 2017 oggi
voglio farvi rivedere il modo in cui un
giovane artista ha 32 anni ha messo 4
pensieri 4 passioni 4 sentimenti in
quattro retrostanze del settecento dei
luoghi con una forza evocativa
straordinaria e dirvi anche brevemente
il perché ho voluto fare questa cosa
innanzitutto per un senso di ambizione
di potermi relazionare e dialogare con
l'antico e in questo senso ho immaginato
in che modo la mia pittura i miei viaggi
la mia esperienza il mio curriculum
e come dire è la ricerca stessa potesse
un certo senso sensibilizzare
l'osservatore a non guardare soltanto
verso l'alto ma a guardare anche su
queste pareti che erano bianche e dove
per anni è stata collocata la collezione
terrae motus e io ho ridisegnato queste
stanze questa è la prima stanza nelle
retrostanze che sta circa 50 metri da
qui e ho
ha realizzato tre grandi tele che sono i
piani sui quali o realizzo i miei nastri
dipinti in acrilico che poi vado a intel
ha reso i dipinti che faccio con lo
scotch e c'è un dipinto per me è molto
importante che ha a che fare molto con
la passione e quindi cade bene anche con
il tema odierno che è questo dipinto al
centro si chiama la stagione dell'amore
la stagione dell'amore e la primavera e
dialoga per l'appunto anche con
quest'affresco primaverile che sta sopra
questi fiori questi uccelli questi
volatili e quindi la possibilità di dire
oggi è possibile ancora fare pittura
farlo con passione farlo con una forma
di riconoscimento e metterla in dialogo
con cosa con un contesto storico antico
importante ma in che modo poi ho
continuato questa è la prima stanza poi
c'è questi sono dei dettagli di questi
quadri dove si vede appunto proprio
tutta la stratificazione del mio lavoro
che passa giorno dopo giorno e la
pittura giorno dopo giorno mi consiglia
proprio delle innovazioni che io
aggiungo e quando sono concentrato nel
mio studio lavorare sento proprio come
dire la pittura stessa mi dà dei
consigli mi offre delle chiave di
entrata ai nuovi percorsi emotivi
questo è un dettaglio sempre della prima
stanza sempre più abbastanza ma passiamo
a come o con il mio lavoro ho cercato di
interpretare l'architettura le
modanature la pittura quindi mettere in
dialogo la pittura antica con come fa
pittura oggi un giovane artista ma
soprattutto questo importante in questo
ambiente due ore si passa da un ambiente
un po più scuro a un ambiente più
illuminato è il modo in cui i borboni in
queste stanze in questi luoghi in questa
grande reggia allestivano le loro opere
i borboni per primi hanno forse del
primo comunque hanno stabilito il
termine probabilmente quadreria le opere
venivano allestiti a mo di quadri a
tant'è vero che nella stanza nella
reggia c'è addirittura un grande
ambiente chiamato quadreria dove ci sono
queste opere e io ho voluto interpretare
personalizzando secondo
linguaggio espressivo ma anche l'idea
del mio linguaggio stesso in polvere
come presentarli come se fosse una
quadreria contemporanea a mo di
costellazione quindi questo secondo
ambiente
ecco questi quali sono un po volanti
hanno una idea di stelle di
costellazioni
qua c'è una uno molto grande che sta
nella parete di stava nella parete di
fronte poi uno di questi quadri sceglie
addirittura del terra ridisegna un
assetto architettonico della reggia e
quasi mette i mezzi netti quasi in primo
piano ottenendo delle luci più scure
sullo sfondo di questo lavoro quindi
terzo ambiente dall'altro lato e qui
vediamo proprio quest opera che si
chiama paradise box che credo sia una
delle mie opere
forse non più riuscite ma forse più
compiute e che mettono più un punto al
mio lavoro in forma policroma e non
monocromatica e dove appunto un quadro
prende una sostanza prendi un corpo
occupa uno spazio diventa quasi una
parete un muro e il muro nella memoria
collettiva immaginifica dell'essere ha
un significato molto molto importante
arriviamo al quarto ambiente dove ci
hanno concesso di realizzare mi hanno
concesso di realizzare un opera
direttamente sulla parete la mia mostra
la reggia e ritorniamo ai sogni e la
passione doveva finire alla stanza
numero 3
ma durante uno dei sopralluoghi con
nicola con il sovrintendente mazzarella
con la curiosità della passione apre una
porta entrò in questa quarta stanza ci
sta sta parete ovviamente senza l'opera
dei segni grigi avete presente come
quando rimangono per anni dei quadri
appesi e c'è una sorta dell'alone del
tempo mi avvicino e vedo l'ora
didascalia dell'opera che era
di che era già nicu nell'isis che è uno
dei più grandi artisti al mondo e
subisco questo attivino di paura poi un
attimo di eccitazione e quindi di
ispirazione chiedo al solo inerente
posso fare un disegno qua sopra
e lì mi dici tu puoi fare quello che
vuoi e quindi ho dipinto nel tempo della
mostra in quattro giorni
questa opera che si chiama in un modo al
quale ho voluto dare anche un titolo
all'opera ma è anche il titolo del mio
intervento oggi titolo dell'opera con la
p e con i piedi per terra con la testa
fra le nuvole e i piedi per terra che
mia
come dire segnato in questo momento
storico mio del mio lavoro
questa mostra questo luogo questo spazio
dove siamo oggi mi ha concesso un sogno
dato ovviamente dalla passione dalla
volontà dalla grinta dal carattere
appunto che caratterizza in un certo
senso ma non mi sono mai voluto
dimenticare della terra la terra inteso
non solo come come dire come piano dove
sisma come senso geografico ma anche
come senso antropologico che è una cosa
molto importante per quanto riguarda nei
per quanto riguarda il mio lavoro da
questi da queste opere poi nascono anche
delle sculture che scorre rapidamente e
anche altri interventi questione la
costiera amalfitana dove c'è quest'opera
che dialoga con il prepo con questo
prepotente barocco se vogliamo così e
questo è ancora una stanza della reggia
di caserta con questo vale che ricorda
un po tutto quello che è la finzione e
la realtà delle modanature degli stucchi
è questa poi è una carrellata di
immagini tornando al discorso iniziale
del mio lavoro di un opera è stata
presentata al museo madre di napoli che
una delle istituzioni museali più
importanti che abbiamo in europa di cui
fortunatamente vantiamo questo
grandissimo museo che ha ospitato questo
lavoro è questa invece è la stessa
stanza sempre del museo madre di napoli
con una mia opera che al momento è in
collezione quindi diciamo che il
percorso reggia sudafrica cuba ma tutta
una serie di esperienze
uno condotto attraverso la passione e
quindi la mia testimonianza di erna a
realizzare dei punti a mettere a segno
delle cose a immaginare che è possibile
oggi fare ancora pittura è possibile
vivere con l'arte è possibile essere un
artista che che viaggia che guarda al
mondo e crea una propria dimensione
artistica dal premier a tutta una serie
di cose questa opera al momento è ancora
in esposizione al museo e qui ritorniamo
su questo ambientale sulla quale io
chiudo la mia
come dire il mio intervento dove c'è
questo appunto si vede proprio questa
grandezza della pittura che oggi ancora
qui in mezzo a noi e mi spiego è
diventato una sorta di fantasma perché è
stata appunto è stato chiesto anche di
lasciarla lì però poi per una serie di
come dire di istituti ne è stata coperta
e poi ragionandoci ho detto ma forse
statuto è stato bene che è stata coperta
però perché rimane una sorta di fantasma
che aleggia si è stratificato nelle mura
di questa immensa regia con i piedi per
terra e la testa fra le nuvole
vi ringrazio
[Musica]